[Music]
this is how the final face of election
campaigning looks like in Istanbul at
the ferry terminal and the kadiköy
district the major parties have set up
their stalls and they are doing their
best to drown each other out this city
has been in campaign mode for almost six
months now he narrowly won the mayor's
office in March Ekrem amalu it was the
first opposition victory here in
Istanbul in 25 years but Ben Ali interim
of the ruling AKP wasn't going to give
up the city without a fight his party
filed complains over irregularities and
obtained a rerun of the election so now
it's round number 2 in the fight for
turkey's most important city a crummy
mamalu has been back on the campaign
trail for weeks he still considers
himself the legitimate mayor of Istanbul
and the decision to rerun the election
politically motivated but she has
accepted it and he's determined to win
again by a decisive margin someone is
awful
of course this election rerun is a waste
of time money and energy and every day
I'm faced with another smear campaign
but this is something we have to deal
with I believe that we will emerge
unscathed and stronger from this
experience the date of the rerun is
another challenge for amalu and his
party the CHP the vote takes place on
June 23rd in the middle of the summer
holidays that's when many people from
Istanbul are usually on vacation but
because the last election was decided by
such a slim margin this time every vote
counts the opposition has even put out
smooth warnings don't go to Bodrum on
June 23rd s heavy snowfall is expected
and the beaches will be shut whether
it's down to the tongue-in-cheek Edwards
or not travel agent gen Polat Allah says
many Istanbul lights have indeed changed
their holiday plans we've had many
elections during summer but I have never
seen something like this five hundred
thousand people from Istanbul have
changed or cancelled their travel plans
so they can be here and vote in the
election the ruling AKP is all so
vigorously campaigning on the streets
their candidate for mayor pinellia
Durham was Turkey's Prime Minister until
last year he's playing on his political
experience but president add one who
held one election rally after another in
support of his man in the initial vote
in spring is now noticeably holding back
nevertheless the party's volunteers say
they're sure of victory
the CHP is definitely trying to create
the impression that they've already won
but we're optimistic in the first round
our votes were stolen and now we're
going to get them back
voters keep telling us that they want
Benally used room for mayor and God
willing people win whoever wins Istanbul
wins turkey is a well-known saying
coined by president ad one himself this
time around many voters in this
significant city would be happy of the
winner of the election would also be
recognized as such and we can go to
Yulia she is in Istanbul for Yulia is
there a clear front-runner at this stage
opinion polls here in Turkey are
considered notoriously unreliable but
most of them show the opposition Canada
a creamy mamalu ahead with up to 8
percentage points but I met president ad
on yesterday in a rare meeting with
foreign journalists where he dismissed
these surveys as manipulative and made
on order the real Paul adorn says would
take place on Sunday so despite the
opposition and a crummy mama Lu being
hopeful that they can win again there is
a lot of uncertainty as to what will
happen on Election Day now Julia you
joined Ekrem Imam Aloha on the campaign
trail who is he what can you tell us
about him well until a few months ago he
was little known even here in Turkey he
was the mayor of an outlying district of
Istanbul but the fact that he narrowly
won the election in March and when was
then stripped of his mandate at the
request of the ruling party propelled
him onto the national stage he has led
an all-embracing grassroots campaign he
has been talking a lot about love and
unity
this might sound
but this has played well with people
here in this highly polarized society
where political language is oftentimes
very aggressive acrimony mamalu
represents a secular leftist party the
CHP but he's also a religious man so he
appeals to conservative voters to
traditional AKP voters as well I talked
to some Istanbul residents here in the
past weeks and I've collected some of
their sound bites why they support mr.
Amaru let's listen to what they had to
tell me boom
the election is very important this time
Imam Oulu will win more decisively and
this could be the beginning of the end
for the ruling party what was done to
him was very unfair he deserves a chance
as mayor that's his right he's trying to
be there for everybody in Istanbul no
matter who they are that's his way of
doing politics and that's why I hope
he'll be our mayor just like a brother
for us he's sincere with in Istanbul got
its beauty back and everybody started
smiling again now this is of course in
mayoral election Yulia but its
significance is so much bigger than that
why well that's because Istanbul is just
so hugely important it's Turkey's
cultural and financial center it makes
up about 1/3 of the country's economy
president edwin was born here he started
his very own political career here when
he became mayor of Istanbul in 1994 so
for him in his party this city means
wealth it means power and prestige
losing it a second time would be a huge
a major blow to mr. arens reputation as
an unbeatable political force that's
what analysts say so really this is not
just an election about who's going to be
mayor of Istanbul but this is an
election that is going to be followed by
millions of people here in the country
and abroad but the question of course is
now will this time around whatever the
outcome is will it be accepted will it
be final well both candidates say they
are going to accept the outcome of this
sir election but of course a victory of
the AKP will probably be greeted by a
lot of suspicion by the opposition
already the decision for rerun has been
met with a lot of criticism I don't
think that mr. Mamun will call on people
to take to the streets in case he loses
but such developments are often quite
difficult to control so we might see
protests but we also might see a week
long battle post election battle for
this important city a city of 16 million
people because no side clearly will let
this city go so easily
all right and one of the world's most
fabled cities that yulia hana reporting
thank you very much